I didn't contest emanuelle Schaefer
notes that the station wagon version of
BMWs 5 Series has been around for 25
years now and this is the fifth
generation the designers first revamped
the sedan then the Touring Car we're
testing the 530 with a 195 kilowatt
diesel engine it launches from zero to
one hundred and five point eight seconds
bMW says it consumes 5.1 liters of fuel
per 100 kilometers
[Music]
the Front's of the touring car and the
sedan are identical both speak the new
BMW design language visually the
kidney-shaped radiator grilles and the
headlights are a single unit one of the
station wagons innovations is the stub
axle which allows a flat cargo floor
it also widens the cargo area and
increases the maximum cargo weight to
720 kilograms
hi-de-ho Amano says many customers
choose the five touring car over other
station wagons in its segment because of
its two-part hatch that hasn't changed
in the fifth generation so you can open
the top of the tailgate and drop in your
shopping bags easy static so know having
to heave up the weight of the whole
tailgate or wait for it to open
electronically
the standard pneumatic suspension
smooths the ride on uneven roadways and
the revised station wagon cuts a good
figure overall on country roads but how
does it perform on the highway
[Music]
deffenbaugh tooling konkow the 5 Series
Touring Car is often used for long trips
or vacation says he Manoa and BMW had
that in mind when looking for things to
improve first was driver comfort BMW
took a look at the suspension and
decided to replace some parts with
lighter ones and then there's the noise
level in the interior BMW added more
insulation without adding much weight
Emanuele thinks the results are
convincing this generation of the 5
station wagon is noticeably quieter than
its predecessor that makes driving more
pleasant even at high speeds you can
drive several hundred kilometers without
having your head throb from all the
noise when you get out of the car at the
end of your journey taking time there
cup women try the so loud bar
I know z'ha'dum in o-positive oh there's
another thing you Manoa likes you know
how when you set off on a winter morning
and it's cold in the car and your hands
get cold but who wants to wear gloves in
the car
of course many manufacturers have
steering wheel heating but where do they
put the control the club fiddling cut
hazel you often spend a long time
looking for it sometimes it's on the
right of the central console sometimes
on the left below the steering wheel
sometimes somewhere else
BMW put the button in the logical place
and the lower middle of the steering
wheel just turn it on and your hands
warm up a simple solution but you have
to think of it first that's practical
for people who often drive different
vehicles plus you don't have to take
your eyes off the road to turn the
heating on or off
Allisyn Emanuel says BMW has made lots
of little improvements to the 5-series
station wagon it still isn't the top of
its segment for trunk volume but it does
hold more than its predecessor the 530d
version he tested starts at just under
50 a thousand euros in Germany